hello this is min young Che and I'm
Anthony cavon I'm sang Only I'm Gia Kim
I'm Anna kathker and we are the cast of
x
what's a quality you look for in a
significant other honesty humor
affection is like
[Music]
no but it's not gonna be just physical
affections
honestly humor loyalty compassion
courage
as well but I'm like oh I'm just like a
funny person yeah it's not the other
ones yeah I think compassion for me
because compassion's like similar to
empathy and I really need empathy yeah
yeah I'm gonna choose honesty okay I'm
way too much of a overthinker for this
um I'm like all of them are good but
then there's this one like I'm weighing
all the options also humor even though I
dissed it at the start pick a song to
play over a big romantic moment
Can't Help Falling in Love by Elvis
Adore You by Harry Styles I Will Always
Love You by Whitney Houston ceilings by
Lizzie mcelfine
I love her I love all of her songs this
love by Taylor Swift
and silk chiffon by Muna and Phoebe
Bridges I'm picking ceilings by
explosion
people like on Tick Tock are like
running through the streets
I'll do I'll Always Love You someone and
I are both cameras
yeah so we're both like Elvis Presley
one human legal names
now we're gonna pick a character to
spend the day with it's John Ambrose
from to all the boys Quincy from Exo
kitty it's weird
driver's line okay
Jeremiah from the samurai turn pretty
cam from the summer I turn pretty Yuri
from Exo kitty Chris from to all the
boys
[Applause]
but not because she's gonna pay for
everything obviously that's a plus hello
but here he's misunderstood I wanna
get under that layer and figure her out
okay guys John Ambrose went to all the
boys always always was like that's my
like I want it on Ambrose so maybe but
also cam from submerging pretty Cam
Cameron I like on popular opinion I was
team Cam Cameron I have to say watching
I was like he but like not for her
because she wasn't right for her but
he's just he deserves better I'll go
search on Ambrose I'm gonna go with Cam
I'm gonna go with Q yeah
[Applause]
choose a book genre we have fantasy
romance young adult horror historical
fiction or biography
young adult I just did a course in
Hawaii writing I'm not gonna pick
anything
else I'm gonna be boring biography I'll
go for a history really
don't do really fiction that much
anymore I used to love it interesting
everyone got their answers yes
I put Romance
choose a place to visit on your next
vacation so there's Seattle there's of
course Seoul New York City Outer Banks
oh London and Paris where's Outer Banks
um the South North Carolina yeah
okay I'm gonna choose pose I think I'm
gonna do the same yeah it's a city of
love City of Lights right you and your
romance novels in Paris
Bakery I really I love that it's driven
by Bread
I love it I want to come yeah let's go
together
I would never pick pairs of these
options I have a snow Club of New York
I'm like I'm gonna move there so I feel
like I have to put New York London okay
all right I've been to London once and I
loved it I want to go again all right
choose a theme for a party you'd love to
attend I love being
I love Barbie masked ball ugly Christmas
sweaters and old Hollywood
I'm gonna go with two thousands pop
icons I feel like there's so many yeah
and the Wardrobe I just went to a 2000s
party and it was great I would love to
do a math ball just because I've never
been to him
I feel like a suit survives thank you
I'll go for an old Hollywood oh I chose
I just I love the movie like uh once
upon a time and I'll do it and like I
just want to feel it
finally pick a beloved Romance movie to
watch tonight guys we're picking we're
gonna have a movie night so carefully I
chose okay the Leo Romeo and Juliet is
actually a fire movie it is Pride and
Prejudice 10 Things I Hate About You
When Harry Met Sally How to Lose a Guy
in 10 Days in Dirty Dancing
you've watched none of these movies
not watched a single one of these what
I'll go for 10 Things I Hate About You
but I'm gonna go with Romeo and Juliet
oh When Harry Met Sally he's like my big
sister's favorite movie or one favorite
movies so I have to pick it because at
least which one is reason when Harry
Mets oh okay okay so I need to watch it
oh sorry oh my god
did we get our results
okay what are we gonna tell each other
our results okay I got belly from the
summer oh my God I got belly too
your personality matches belly you're
passionate funny and sincere like belly
you're ready to start your big adventure
and you're looking to finally step out
of your shell and make the most out of
your life
so good your family is very important to
you and you will do anything for them
you believe in your perfect soul mate
and you either have found them or are
still searching
I got Kitty no I know it actually
very accurate
you got Kitty from extra Kitty your
personality matches Kitty your ambitious
hard-working and Charming like kitty
you're a hopeless romantic plain and
simple you're someone who sees a
potential in others often before they
even see it in themselves you crave
adventure and want to make the most out
of life
[Music]
[Applause]
your personality matches day you're
intelligent friendly and practical yeah
like today you make friends pretty
easily true which is why you might be
seen as part of the popular crowd while
you're someone who is also trying to do
the best it can sometimes land you into
some Sicky sticky situations
everything I said is very accurate
you're learning to follow your heart
when it matters most oh that's so cute
that was fun
EXO Kitty only on Netflix
[Music]
foreign